Specialized sub circuits and they're
variable in their expression.
And what that basically means is
that on average across people,
they're likely to be
located in the same place.
Now there's,
there's,
there's some discrepancies
cause lefthanders are
different than right handers
and people also have mixed dominance.
And so their brains can be organized
in ways that are not exactly cononical.
So we're saying roughly speaking,
and it extends,
it extends in some weird ways to phenomena
that you wouldn't necessarily think
could possibly be
organized in that manner.
So for example,
the part of the brain that you use for
silent reading and the visual Cortex is
back here.
And then the auditory
cortex is about here.
And then the part of the brain that
you use for silent reading is where the
auditory and the visual cortex overlap.
So that's pretty cool.
So what it means is that you look at
words and you'll hear them because your
eyes are using the auditory cortex
as a representational structures.
That's pretty cool.
And so it turns out that people who silent
read pretty much used the same brain
area to do that.
And so you might think about that as
biological preparedness in some sense.
But of course,
people didn't learn to read
silently til 500 years ago,
roughly speaking.
You know,
even the earliest literate people,
most of them read out loud,
silent reading was a very,
very rare phenomenon.
Julius Caesar could read silently and
people thought that that was part of his
magical power because it's,
well,
it's pretty damn weird.
You know,
that you can use your eyes to here,
you know,
cause you can all do it.
You think,
yeah,
anybody can do that.
But you know,
it's a pretty new thing on
the evolutionary horizon.
And to be able to hear with your eyes,
it's like good work guys.
That's,
that's not an easy thing to manage.